joining me now is Omid Malik who's the
founder and CEO of farvahar Partners
Omid good to see you tonight now this
broke just moments ago Silicon Valley
Bank CEO Tim mayopolis says they are
conducting business as usual within the
United States and expect to resume
cross-border transactions in the coming
days your reaction
well this is probably just uh out of the
receivership in bankruptcy context that
they put in a new CEO and that they're
going to uh try to give whatever
semblance of ordinary course that they
can but make no mistake I mean
ultimately what will happen here is that
every Equity holder of this bank will be
completely wiped out and as you point
out that's the right thing we didn't do
that in 2008 and if there's one silver
lining in this terrible story is that
every Equity holder needs to be wiped
out because as you point out that's
capitalism
but Roku isn't wiped out right
Roblox
their deposits are covered
that's right I mean look in the context
of the last few months we've had the
largest Ponzi scheme in U.S history
under FTX we've had the second and third
largest bank failures with SBB and
signature
um and this Administration made the
decision to protect the depositors I
think it's an interesting question
depositors are different than Equity
holders and bondholders and the
management team in my opinion but that
said I don't think you can retroactively
apply the rules here I think there need
to be a clean course of action and the
administration didn't do that it does
smack of a white collar bailout as
you're pointing out it seems to me that
this was a very politically connected
group of folks in Silicon Valley that do
have undue influence
but we also need to be very considerate
of
contagion how do we make sure that this
government right now is not responsible
for every deposit in the country because
it seems like that's the case
well exactly so my point in the angle
was that
while the argument is oh there's a going
to be a contagion of contagion of run
run on Bank situation across the country
your point is it could sweep the other
way so the contingent is just let the
money roll go over 250 000 the bank's
going to be the bank's going to be
ultimately uh rescued and the depositors
will ultimately be made whole even
though they know the rules are made
yeah no I mean I think that the bank
definitely should not be rescued none of
the management team should I mean just
take SVP for an example I mean this is
not uh an institution that acted with uh
without impunity I mean this is a this
is an institution quite frankly that was
more concerned with getting an A plus
ESG rating uh Dei policies didn't have a
risk manager at all last year okay and
conducted no risk management as a
related to uh interest rate risk so I
want them to fail I think we're on the
same page here the only novel question
for us all was what to do with
depositors and you're saying that the
depositors of this Bank should be should
lose their assets because of the type of
depositors that they are I don't want
the other Regional Banks to be harmed
that's the only point I'm making because
Regional banks are extremely important
in our country we do not want every
American to have to bank with the four
largest too big to fail companies so my
big emphasis here is we have to protect
Regional Banks because if all all the
power is concentrated in the four
largest banks that's effectively having
the government control our assets and I
don't think that's anything any of us
want you only have to look to what
happened in Canada when you had the
truckers protesting the vaccine mandates
to see that the government can actually
touch our bank accounts the more the
farther away that banks are are from the
federal government the more Liberty and
protection that we have and I believe
that Regional Banks I need to do that
they protect I agree with you yeah yeah
I agree with you on the Regional Bank
question however there is a rule in
place that looks like it can be lifted
whenever a connected group of people
gets in trouble which is the 250 000
limit the rule is there but now it can
just be dispensed with when somebody's
abidance who are important for his
re-election are are upset so I I feel
like that's a real problem by the way
Signature Bank we just got these videos
from genvieve
um uh Roche we'll put it back up on the
screen so I can actually read it
genvieve Roche dector a money manager
who has been on the show she's terrific
she says she spoke with someone who
worked at Signature Bank which obviously
ran into the same trouble for several
years saying the management team was
basically like the show the office that
wastes money on things like producing
parody videos here's one of the ones she
was talking about watch this meetings
some things will sell the souls some
makes just Fury alone I wish they were a
soul look the only way we're gonna do
this thing is if we start a bank and of
course the federal government had to you
know jump in Sunday night because this
one was going to go down as well quickly
Omid uh how can we take Banks like this
seriously and that certainly isn't one I
imagine you thought you think should be
protected
look of course I mean that that that is
sickening and absurd what you just
showed me um but it's kind of indicative
of where we are I'd also point out that
Barney Frank was on the board of
signature uh and the irony of that as
someone who is the namesake of
Dodd-Frank who's now upset that uh you
know the chickens came home to roost
here no we can't be protecting these
kinds of banks it's a broader point I'll
close with Laura though is that wokism
has supplanted Merit uh across our
country and you're seeing the
ramifications of that in the banking
sector and we can't reward that behavior
whatsoever and you're right we have to
be very concerned about regular American
people are getting the short end of the
stick I'm with you 100 on that oh
Omid great to see you tonight thank you
so much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else